[Music]
in outside the box news submitted by
name-brand shirt no a student got top
marks for writing an essay in invisible
ink oh that's a Bart [ __ ] right there
ah so it's cool cuz she's a ninja
student what how do you be a ninja
student why are you writing something in
ninja school she was doing the clerical
work for an interest I see
it's like you got a ninja badass FBI
school and you're just like checking HR
the ninja intern that's Joe right now
the ninja intern still studying this
Japanese student of ninja history oh so
she handed in a blank paper PO work for
her si that's tie and it came along with
like a little set of instructions and so
her pickle orange peel and rub it on and
then it activates the ink on paper
hey how little though can you tell me
how little like he said I get a little
book like this oh no it's not like a
magnifying glasses student oh so then
after the the orange peels so they had
to like she wasn't fooling around yeah
so the the professor had to put it over
like a burning stove so like what the
heat it activated bets up ninja [ __ ] oh
and then I'll tell you how she prepared
it cuz she spent hours like doing it the
old ninja way of like how it used to do
invisible [ __ ] yeah I invisible ink did
you know that joke it says one one nine
zero six
what's one nine zero so cool I know I
want to be one go back to it I was
reading half of it oh you could read it
yeah
what does it say is on the right is's
one one nine zero six and then it says
man I wish my Chinese was better part no
the other part I don't know
I need more Chinese school one one nine
one six yeah that's that silly part that
I know cool now we know what it's about
like a house one and then the one with
like so how did they read the invisible
part and then the door like there's one
over here yeah and then it appears Oh
like so if there's heat in it shows up
so she followed the ninja technique of a
bah-bah she buried - oh [ __ ] that's uh
dashi is bring out ha so I would add oil
and then dashi is like bringing it out
so it's like bringing oil yeah they're
probably using oil to to market so the
way she did is she soaked soybeans
overnight and then she crushed them and
then she squeezed them in a cloth and
then she mixed the soy bean extract with
water spending two hours to get the
concentration right before she started
writing her essay with the fine brush on
washi paper so ninjas had access to that
many soybeans it wasn't a lot going on
back then that's true just just got like
a piece of paper and said like genius
she got an A yeah I was thinking the
little Spencer's gifts like invisible
ink pens where you like write it and
then it disappears and I was like patina
would disappear before the teacher saw
it you know there's a shortage of ninjas
right now oh you're joking no I'm not
joking wants to apply because there's a
ninja theme park and there's not enough
ninja performers and then they're like
we need ninjas it will pay like 70 grand
a year so like break ninja code if they
like show their identities like they're
doing performer I just know they're fake
ninjas so it's like the medieval times
of Japan yeah but he's just subscribed
they should really subscribe because
we're trying to hit 2 million and that's
when ninjas will appear but until we hit
that you guys will never have ninjas
around us so subscribe so the professor
said I didn't hesitate to give the full
marks how does she even know to heat up
the paint or does she tell her oh I did
it
- away no you couldn't read one one nine
zero six yes Capri that was giving
instructions to the professor because
she didn't want him to throw the paper
in the trash yeah so when he says I had
seen such reports written in code but
I'd never seen one done in a boy I
thought she to tell you the truth I mean
to tell the truth I had a little doubt
that the words would come out clearly
but when I actually heated the paper
over the gas stove in my house the words
appeared very clearly and I thought well
done I didn't hesitate to give the
report full marks even though I didn't
read it to the very end because I
thought I should have I should leave
some part of the paper and heat it in
case the media would somehow find this
and take a picture
that's it that's it I didn't even know
you could major in ninja studies it's
ninja history wait yeah the media can't
can't know what that says is my secret
ninja stuff no it's not what's it I see
I thought maybe like in ninja history
school it's other people aren't allowed
to know what what they're learning oh
yeah I think it's real man just go
that's awesome i smuggles i wonder if
it's like for PE they have to do like
invisible [ __ ] like that but like hot
like throw a smoke bomb and hide in like
there's like tests on that yeah he's
like Hogwarts yeah well I hope I imagine
there's like a sorting probably the only
loser going this far and above
she's Hermione know the professor did
clarify or like when he gave out the
assignment he says that he would give
extra points for creativity oh so that's
why she decided to make her stand out
one of the tests look like you gotta
appear out of nowhere so when he comes
into class the kids [ __ ] fall from
the roof in like they like turn into
like desks and [ __ ] that's tight they
just come out of the wall yeah kind of
cool
I bet it's all boring bill like it's out
of university and they're just studying
like ninja history is it like a major or
just someone class I don't know they
just say ninja history good thing right
the the message in poison ink haha but
then the professor would give extra
credit right before they died good thing
if you coat it in your school and you
graduate it and you learn all this [ __ ]
oh what's the first thing you do what
what'd I do with it yeah oh [ __ ] kill
somebody oh [ __ ] okay next person Thank
You same question I would hide all the
time and no one would be able to see me
but I could see them and I can know what
they're saying and then I can blackmail
them we have been just evil well we have
a ninja school it's called the CIA all
true but it doesn't look cool I'm just
kidding I wouldn't blackmail anyone I
would just want to like be head Steve
doing dumb [ __ ] now she's boring
really she is special option do it oh my
god I know what you could use their
powers for beauty sneaking up on Steve
in it who would it be like oh yeah
because he doesn't hear me like walking
in the rooms a lot and so like if he's
a-cookin or whatever like I'll be like
standing right behind him and then he
turns around he's like hey why are you
doing what are you doing and but the way
he reacts is less than that yeah so I
don't get the satisfaction of seeing his
surprised face he goes he turns around
he's like oh why so like when I show up
randomly she gets scared too and I never
understand why cuz I'm a [ __ ] there's
your answer
so the whole time you were thinking
about being an enema Eminem's closet
like you would learn all this stuff
breaking his house being his glory yeah
I just beyond like you know maybe all
the outside so what you're gonna knock
on the door no but minja skills you get
it you got to take it all the legs it's
like what's the point of grinning you
know he walks out of his house so I'm
not breaking and entering but it also
knows like and he's like oh [ __ ] how'd
you do that I'm like I'm a ninja
hey I'm Nikki and then two Rottweilers
jump out in the name stupid so they all
write a song about me
the ninja ninja coming to meet again in
August yeah that's all the stuff you did
better than I did I want to dress the
president in now hey yeah and then you
guys won't know I'm a villain ninja for
Halloween one will know who you are cuz
you're the tall one
upwards at work everyone I'm gonna tell
Steven yes that would be done cuz that
make me really happy and then people are
gonna know for sure who it is this
[ __ ] dude with big ass least I get my
toes like this ha ha I think's been
loving wearing those socks like he wears
them around the ninja song I was like
are you wearing your socks with sandals
on he's like no they're like this he was
so proud that's like what does he have
ninja songs yeah you thought he likes
them look at Jess is like are you
walking on those upside-down because it
was all dirty on the top number toe
socks it's like junior high I never was
so cool
you like them they freak me out it looks
like gloves on feet yeah like those are
weird I don't like it just feeling the
fabric between every single toe yeah I
don't like it now but back then I
thought it was so cool
did you wear them with flip-flop yeah oh
you're wrong let me save a Barbara it's
a beach town everyone's wearing
flip-flops when it gets cold why stop
but gets cold but not cold enough for
pants or for clothes - it's cold but
you're wearing sandals and in your sock
socks so just wear shoes because I want
to show up with toes
and then you wonder what you didn't have
a friend know if it's bad
were they all colorful and striped and
stuff I pictured that too probably saw
you from a mile away
there's Mickey run away I was a
trendsetter okay still AM
you set the trend and no one followed so
my friends used to do that in Ohio maybe
I did it toe socks or trend-setting
well you're just as cool as people in
Ohio you hear that you know it's true
that's what you're here in la night that
is true there are losers out there huh
but there's no traffic there Oh drop the
mic
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]